sie haben gesagt sie möchten über das
sprechen wo sie sich wirklich auskennen
und aus ihrer Sicht traurigerweise
kennen sie sich glaube ich schon auch
über die Gründe aus warum Kirchenbänke
sie haben das selbst gerade gesagt immer
Lehrer werden über dieses Thema wollen
wir gleich sprechen wir wollen aber auch
es liegt vorhin über ihr neues Buch
sprechen denn sie haben mit dem
künstlich verstorbenen Papst Benedikt
das letzte große Gespräch geführt und
haben einiges mitgenommen aus diesem
Gespräch einiges vielleicht auch gelernt
und einiges hier heute mitgebracht dass
Sie mit uns teilen möchten es ist ihre
Zeit ihre Kamera und ihr Thema ja also
es ist nicht das letzte große Gesprächen
Gegenteil das Gespräch hat aber hier
drauf auf jeden Fall unser letzt
es Cover da muss man aber jedesmal ernst
nehmen
ja unser letztes Gespräch das war
überhaupt nicht das letzte große
Gespräch geführt hat das hat er
wahrscheinlich mit Herz rein geführt
oder mit Papst Franzis
also es war so ich war in einer Talkshow
bei Markus Lanz und Markus Lanz hat mir
anschließend gesagt weil er wusste ich
habe da Kontakte vatikaner auch Papst
Benedikt seit 40 Jahren er hätte
wirklich das große Anliegen noch einmal
Papst wenig zu begegnen habe den mal
interviewen das habe ich ihn zutiefst
berührt
oder habe ich im tief in die Augen
geguckt und gefragt meinst das wirklich
so und das meinte er wirklich so und
dann habe ich das organisiert dann waren
wir aber 2018 eben er hat danach auch
nicht mehr sehr laut geredet aber es war
das letzte das letzte Gespräch haben wir
dann ein Gespräch mit ihm geführt und
wir hatten erst gar nicht beabsichtigt
das als Buch zu veröffentlichen dann war
es aber so überraschend was er sagt und
dann war es auch so beeindruckend was er
sagte dass er gedacht haben das müssen
wir einfach dokumentieren und haben das
dann als Buch herausgegeben jetzt nach
seinem nach seinem Tod ähm bin ich der
16 unser letztes Gespräch und ähm Markus
Lanz hat da finde ich sehr sehr sensibel
noch mal berichtet was er dafür einen
Zugang hat und ich habe aus meiner
40-jährigen Erfahrung mit ihm berichtet
und Markus Lanz er hat auch mit Recht
geschrieben dass er kaum jemanden kennt
wo das öffentliche Image dem der
Realität so widerspricht also ist zum
Beispiel einer der humorvollsten
Menschen die ich überhaupt kenne der hat
Spaß an Humor an Ironie und so weiter
von morgens bis abends also sind
wirklich und geistreich natürlich immer
auch einer der gescheitesten Menschen
die ich kenne wenn ich den getroffen
habe dann hat er das Gespräch meistens
da fortgesetzt wo wir von einem Jahr
aufgehört haben das war mir immer ganz
unheimlich weil ich an meinem Gedächtnis
etwas gezweifelt habe aber er ist vor
allem und das muss man mal betonen ein
großer Theologe gewesen alles andere hat
eben nicht gerne gemacht er ist nicht
gerne Erzbischof von München gewonnen
hat Ersatzpflicht als religiöse Pflicht
auf sich genommen er ist nicht gerne
perfekte Glaubens Konjugation geworden
um Leuten zu sagen das geht aber nicht
und so oder er hat sich massiv mit
Händen und Füßen dagegen gewehrt
Johannes Paul II hat gesagt du musst
jetzt aber es geht nicht mehr und dann
hat er gesagt ich will wenigstens weiter
publizieren können das ist normalerweise
nicht üblich der perfekte Glauben
feststellen ob das katholisch oder nicht
und ich selber noch Bücher schreiben und
ähm ja dann vielleicht auch kritisiert
muss oder so sondern
er wollte weiter auch gemacht und er und
selbst seine heftigsten Gegner
bestreiten nicht dass er nicht gerne
Platz geworden sie hat das auf sich
genommen und hat auch selbst ganz offen
geschrieben das hat er uns auch gesagt
ich habe gar keine Fähigkeit für so
einen Job ja
er ist ein großer Theologe er hat 1968
vor über 50 Jahren seinen ersten großen
Bestseller geschrieben die Einführung
des Christentum großer beste und ich
habe vor einem Jahr nachdem er das
Gespräch geführt haben ihn noch mal
gefragt ob ich eine Kurzfassung davon
machen kann von der Einführung des
Christentum so populär weil da sind auch
Anmerkungen und so das ist nichts für
nicht Wissenschaftler und dem hat er
dann noch schriftlich zugestimmt dann
habe ich noch eine Kurzfassung gemacht
die hat auch noch abprobiert die kommt
jetzt im Mai raus da kann man auch 250
Seiten lesen was ist das Wesentliche des
Christentums und das das ist ein
bisschen der Punkt den sie am Anfang
Ansprachen das halte ich für wichtig
dass die Menschen wieder wissen was ist
das entscheidende des Christentums das
ist nicht die Frage zu debat ja oder
nein da reden die Leute alle drüber also
auf meinem sterbe wird mich nicht die
Frage nach dem zu dem Bad interessieren
sollen die Frage Luthers wie bekomme ich
ein gnädigen Gott und darüber müssten
aber mehr reden in der Kirche also die
Frage existiert Gott das hat Ratzinger
interessiert darüber hat geschrieben es
gibt Menschen die durch dieses Buch die
einfach in das Christentum zum Glauben
gekommen sind und in diesen 250 Seiten
was ist das Christentum was ist das
wichtige des christentumsatz was das
bedeutet in der Nächstenliebe was das
bedeutet Toleranzen christliche
Erfindungen ja so das wissen die
Christen ja noch nicht mal das ist das
wesentlich und in diesem Buch sind
vielleicht drei Seiten drei vier Seiten
über die Kirche das muss man sich auch
mal klar machen ja wenn man denkt ja der
Ratzinger ist wir haben ihn gefragt ich
habe ihn gefragt hören Sie mal sie waren
beim Weltjugendtag in Köln ja eine
Million Jugendliche ich habe das mal
genau mir durchlesen die haben keinen
einzigen Satz zur sexual Moral gesagt
nicht sie haben über den Glauben die
Schönheit des Glaubens geredet übrigens
Glauben an Gott übernächsten Liebe bei
Engagement für Menschen in Not und so
aber nichts über Sex zu haben Moral ja
ganz bald hatte immer viel darüber
geredet vergleichsweise viel und er hat
gesagt das hat ihn auch nie sehr
interessiert ja aber dennoch sind auch
von Journalisten immer diese Themen an
ihn herangetragen worden sind jetzt für
dagegen Kondome und sowas und das war
eine Sache er war Theologe
heute Menschen die Schönheit des des
christlichen Glaubens vermitteln und
dieser Text ist wirklich wenn man ihn
befreit auch von diesen
wissenschaftlichen Dingen das habe ich
dann gemacht wirklich ein funkelnder
Text mit mit tollen Formulierungen und
ich glaube wir als Deutsche eigentlich
ein bisschen stolz darauf sein dass er
eigentlich der eine vielleicht der
wichtigste Theologe des 20 Jahrhunderts
ist und wir haben den in so kleine
Schubladen getan dass man nur noch über
die Frage des Missbrauchs redet nur noch
über die Frage der Sexualmoral da ist er
in vielen Fällen vielleicht nicht
geschickt mit umgegangen ich habe das
selbst erlebt oder nicht im Vatikan war
Papst Benedikt oder schon keine
Ratzinger der radikalste der gegen
Missbrauch gekämpft hat ich war bei
einer bei einer geheimtagung hat weil
ich eingeladen 1999 mit dem Führerschein
sozusagen mit den Spitzen der Kurie und
er war der Einzige der klar gesagt hat
nein diese Priester wir müssen uns von
den trennen es geht nicht dass es so
schrecklich ja und die anderen sagten
alle muss man auch nicht so streng
nehmen oder sowas und das heißt dieser
Mut dieses dieses kleinen schmächtigen
Mannes der hat mich der hat mich schon
sehr beeindruckt deswegen finde ich die
Art und Weise wie dann damit umgegangen
worden ist sehr ungerecht ich habe
dieses Münchner Gutachten gelesen das
ist einfach in dem Punkt auch zum Teil
zum Teil wertlos ja die haben die haben
8000 Seiten durchgekackt und haben kein
einzigen wirklichen Beweis dass er
überhaupt was wusste über solche Fälle
da muss man natürlich darüber
diskutieren warum hat man ihm das nicht
gesagt hätte er nicht seine Sache so
organisieren müssen dass die Leute ihm
das sagen ja darüber kann reden es gab
keine Beweise und deswegen finde ich und
das ist auch Sinn dieses Buch was ich
mit Markus Lanz geschrieben habe dass
man Papst Benedikt mal wieder in
Deutschland entdeckt sozusagen
von ihm muss man sagen und ich glaube
würden sie wahrscheinlich vor vielen
Jugendlichen so darüber sprechen kämpfen
vielleicht bei dem ein oder anderen
erstmal die Frage auf dem Winter klingt
interessant der Mann über den möchte ich
mehr erfahren bittere Wahrheit ist so
ist es ja irgendwie leider nicht und
zwar mit der gesamten katholischen
Kirche derzeit sie haben es angesprochen
immer weniger Bänke sind besetzt immer
weniger vor allem von jungen Menschen
woran fehlt es da sie haben gesagt
natürlich wir haben übers Personal
sozusagen gesprochen aber stimmt die
Botschaft noch ist es eine Botschaft die
junge Menschen noch erreicht also ich
glaube dass die Debatten die wir in
Deutschland zum Teil führen ich mache
mich da gar nicht lustig drüber Frage zu
die Bart oder Frauen diagonat oder
sexual Moral Fragen sind die viele
Katholiken bewegen aber ich habe zum
Beispiel dafür plädiert die katholische
Kirche sollte ein zehnjähriges Buch
Schweigen zu sexuellen Fragen einhalten
sie sollte einfach die den Mund halten
Klappe halten ich bin nicht Christ wegen
der sexual sondern ich bin christlich an
Gott Glaube an Jesus Christus Glaube und
weil ich uneigennützig Flüchtlingen
anderen Menschen helfen will und so das
ist Sinn Sinn meines christlichen Lebens
und auch auf dem Sterbebett wird mir
nicht die Sexualmoral interessieren
sondern so das heißt wir reden wir sind
fixiert auf diese Themen und das finde
ich auch ein Problem ich bin beim
Weltjugendtag in Madrid gewesen aber
Papst Benedikt damals und ich habe ich
kann mich noch gut erinnern ich stand da
abends sah eine Million Menschen aus der
ganz junge Menschen aus der ganzen Welt
die diesen Mann zujubelten und die
begeistert waren von dieser Zärtlichkeit
dir so ausstrahlte also das war
berührend und da habe ich mir überlegt
66 Jahre nach dem schrecklichen Zweiten
Weltkrieg wo die deutschen diese diese
Schrecken über die Welt gebracht haben
jubeln eine Million jugendlich aus der
ganzen Welt diesen deutschen sie sagen
es gibt sie zumindest noch aber ich habe
auch schweres Atmen gehört bei Ihnen bei
Christian Waldorf Christian mit Vornamen
Mitglied der CDU aber Klappe zu jetzt
wird einfach mal geschwiegen also
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das der
richtige Weg ist ich glaube die Analyse
zeigt bin selbst katholisch und das
wissen die allerwenigsten bis zur
zehnten Klasse wurde sogar selbst mal
Priester werden und sie ist da nicht so
gekommen aus gewissen Gründen die man
halt herzlich schmunzeln aber ich glaube
das Problem ist woanders sie können das
in der jetzigen Phase in der sich die
katholische Kirche befindet und im
Übrigen auf die protestantische Kirche
übertragen wird da sind ja auch eine
ganze Menge Austritte drin können Sie
das nicht mehr stoppen ich glaube eher
es geht nur mit offenem Visier weil was
wenn sie jetzt beginnen nichts mehr zu
sagen wird ihnen das auch keiner
abnehmen ich sage nur wir müssen über
andere Themen reden junge Leute nicht
daran interessiert ja da gebe ich Ihnen
erzählt Wiese Sex machen sollen ja das
ist ja also selbst konservative
Katholiken nicht die die sagen immer am
Abend vor vor der Hochzeitsnacht noch
mal den Papst anrufen wollen was mache
ich jetzt hat der Vater oder die machen
was sie was sie richtig finden ja und äh
aber auch schon mal ja aber die Zahlen
sind lang vorbei die katholische Kirche
hat ihre Autorität auch in Fragen der
Sexualmoral völlig eingebüßt wir können
aber die Gründe reden aber dass ich als
wurscht ich glaube wir müssen mehr über
das reden was ist der Sinn des Lebens
also leider haben sie Recht die Frage ja
und junge Leute haben die wir haben
jetzt über der über die jungen Kinder da
gesprochen wurde inzwischen jung und
Kinder andere jungen Kinder umbringen
oder so etwas wir müssen wieder Werte
vermitteln und dafür ist es wichtig
schon auch über den Glauben an Gott zu
reden über über und es gibt die etwas
bildenden Verbände sind nun mal die
Kirche noch nicht die Tennisclubs nein
oder haben Sie Recht und wenn man da
anschließt wäre mein Wunsch auch als
praktizieren der Katholik es fehlt
schlichtweg das hat auch was mit der
Menge der Person zu tun die wir noch
haben es fehlt schlichtweg an der
Seelsorge weil sie ganz andere Probleme
im Moment zu meistern haben die sind
Verwaltungs technische Probleme an
andere Dinge ich hätte mir übrigens mehr
Mut gewünscht das muss ich auch sagen es
gab ja mal einen Papst Johannes den 23
der hat sehr sehr gute und sehr sehr
wegweisende Vorschläge gemacht das
allerdings in den 70ern und in den 60er
Jahren 60er Jahren vor allem die sind
halt nie so weit gekommen und dass wir
ich frage mal andersrum überhaupt
darüber diskutieren dass Frauen da nicht
in Frage kommen dass wir überhaupt
darüber diskutieren dass nicht
geheiratet werden darf das ist kein
Wunsch von Jesus gewesen in seinem
Konzil beschlossen worden dass diese
Dinge heute in der Zeit in der die
Seelsorge so wichtig wäre das was sie
sagen die Wertevermittlung überhaupt so
lange diskutiert wenn du verstehe ich
nicht gelöst werden aber wir haben einen
speziell deutsches Problem natürlich wir
haben so eine deutsche Babbel und denken
die Themen auch die Synodalen weg sein
die wichtigsten Themen es ist in
Deutschland überhaupt nicht aufgefallen
dass Papst franziskus vor einem halben
Jahr das Kardinalskollegium abgeschafft
hat die Faktor das hat keiner gemacht ja
Papst franziska hat vor von einem halben
Jahr entschieden dass das
tausend Jahre lang war das der Senat des
Papst wann die führenden Berater des
Papstes und jetzt können alle führenden
Behörden des Vatikan von Frauen geleitet
werden das steht noch nicht mehr in der
Zeitung ja das frage ich mich auch warum
schlechtes Marketing dann
lesen das kann man im Internet auch
nachlesen ja das heißt Nachfolgerin von
von Kardinal Ratzinger als perfekt der
glaubenskongression kann nächsten Monat
eine Frau werden wo steht das bitte in
der Zeitung und ich finde wir müssten
mal von dir und wir diskutieren im Sinne
deinen Weg wird über das Frauen diagonat
geredet Diakonie heißt dienen ja dann
wird sozusagen die dienstfunktion der
Frau auch noch sakralisiert ich finde
das kein riesen Fortschritt und dann
kann die Frau am Ende der heiligen Messe
sagen geht hin in Frieden ich finde es
ist wichtiger dass Frauen mehr Macht in
der Kirche haben
da glaube ich läuft das und das ist auch
glaube ich die Strategie von Papst
franziskus sondern darüber dass dass die
Kleriker Macht abgeben an Leim an Leute
wie sie und da ist es höchste Zeit da
werden ja über den glauben Sie dass man
Jugendliche überhaupt noch für solche
Themen begeistern kann wie tief steckt
die Kirche aus ihrer Sicht in der Krise
ja ich bin ja ich bin evangelisch seit
wird und ich bin da Zahlen des Mitglied
ums mal so auszudrücken und letztlich
glaube ich dass wir in einer säkularen
Gesellschaft reden also um es mal ein
bisschen zuzuspitzen man könnte auch
sagen die katholische Kirche ist eine
Art Tennisclub wo sich nur noch die
Tennisspieler für interessieren aber
ansonsten ist die ausstrahlungswirkung
in die Gesellschaft mittlerweile glaube
ich
äußerst reduziert um es nicht
zuzuspitzen und natürlich hat heute kein
Jugendlicher mehr interessiert sich
eigentlich dafür welche Meinung hat die
katholische Kirche zu sexuellen Fragen
zu Homosexualität oder so ich habe noch
niemand getroffen der sich in der
Beziehung an der Kirche relevant genau
aber was da natürlich zum Ausdruck kommt
wir haben gerade über den Islam
gesprochen und über Moscheen
offensichtlich haben wir spirituelles
Defizit
und ähm wir müssen reden
also ich bin
dieses Defizit wird glaube ich zum Teil
in solchen Bewegungen wie letzte
Generation auch schon letzte
Generationen kompensiert oder so das hat
ja auch sehr viel spirituelle quasi
religiös aber Religion eine neue quasi
ja das bekommt natürlich dann das ist ja
auch nicht alles ganz neu also zum
Beispiel 20er Jahren der Marxismus der
hatte auch schon so etwas sektenartiges
und so aber was ich wirklich
was sie wirklich bezweifle ist ob die
katholische Kirche
selber intern das was sie so schön in
ihrem Buch jetzt auch beschreiben wollen
ob sehr viele Katholiken das überhaupt
noch wissen das heißt also die eigenen
Überzeugung die eigene Ideologie die
eigene ideologischen Grundlagen
religiösen theologischen Grundlagen sind
glaube ich ihren Katholiken heute gar
nicht mehr klar es geht um die
Gesellschaft insgesamt ich habe in
Weimar ich will das immer sagen ich habe
den Weimar äh bei einer gesamten
Oberstufe 300 atheistische Oberstufen
Schüler ein Vorteil gehalten über Gott
ja ich habe mein Buch geschrieben Gott
eine kleine Geschichte das größte habe
ich auch Kabarett zu gemacht und habe da
geredet es war eine der spannendsten
Diskussionen die ich geführt habe die
waren alle interessiert die Frage was
ist der Sinn des Lebens warum lebe ich
eigentlich ja gibt es sowas wie eine
letzte Instanz ob man die jetzt Gott
nennt oder nicht das ist auch für junge
Menschen interessant aber unsere in
kircheninternen Debatten ja die arkone
oder oder oder was weiß ich oder oder
Sexualmoral oder so oder sagen die also
Opa g ja also das interessiert mich ja
aber spirituelle Fragen finde ich auch
in evangelischen Kirche zum Beispiel er
hat immer fragen nein nein nein der ist
Frau kessmann z.B die schreibt
Bestseller eine nach dem anderen wenn
sie überzeugend auch spirituelle Fragen
beantworten dann dann kommen die Leute
auch junge Menschen also unsere Töchter
wir haben 45 Jugendliche bei uns über
zehn Jahre immer eingeladen da haben die
so so rallycamp nannte sich das vier
vier Tage lang und die sind inzwischen
die gehen alle immer noch in die Kirche
sind fromm aber ziemlich feierfreudig
also nicht verklemmt das heißt das geht
ja aber man muss den Mut haben das dann
auch zu machen und ich finde Christen
auch in unserem Alter müssen sich dann
vielleicht auch mal bekennen ja das tun
wir ja eigentlich nicht die katholischen
Tradition wir beide schonen
das ist aber sozusagen katholisch auch
nicht üblich also katholisch ist man
einfach selbstverständlich und da redet
man nicht dauernd über seinen Glauben
weil wir aber vor 30 Jahren darüber auch
nicht haben reden müssen also völlig
normal war natürlich in unserem Alter
jetzt feststellen dass es eben nicht
mehr aber
auch machen
ich würde sagen genau
vielleicht ein spirituelles Defizit hat
er da stellte sich solche Fragen sind er
sich nach sowas ist für ihn die Kirche
überhaupt noch irgendwie interessant ich
muss mal sagen im biblischen Sinne muss
ich jetzt mal Wasser in den Wein gießen
das klingt alles wunderbar und auch das
spirituelle sicherlich was ganz
wichtiges aber das interessiert junge
Menschen erst dann wenn natürlich etwas
ausgesendet wird und das tut die Kirche
nicht das hat ihn der corona-krise nicht
wo war die Kirche denn der corona-krise
ich bin selber Katholik die Kirche
bemüht überhaupt nicht und
Sexualmoral darum geht es nicht aber
diese missbrauchsgeschichten und sie
sagen auf der einen Seite das Gutachten
sagt naja der Papst wusste ja gar nichts
auf der anderen Seite sagen sie in dem
geheimzirkel hat er gesagt das muss
aufhören die müssen weg diese Priester
dürfen Moment aber er hat dann auch was
gemacht ich habe 2003 den erst mit
Ratzinger zusammen den ersten
vatikanischen missbrauchskongress
organisiert ist auch publiziert worden
weil er das wollte also wir haben eine
Debatte geführt ja auch eine
wissenschaftliche Debatte darüber das
was er halt tun konnte aber sagen wir
mal so Missbrauch ich finde Missbrauch
durch katholische Priester und Ordner
ist schlimmer als jeder andere
missbraucht ist die die jungen Leute
verlieren ja nicht nur das Vertrauen in
Menschen auch das Vertrauen in Gott und
deswegen ist die Kirche besonders
betroffen dadurch ich glaube das was wir
in Deutschland machen als Missbrauchs
Aufarbeitung der Bischofskonferenz
weitgehend ehrlich gesagt gescheitert
ist ja also ähm ich plädiere seit zehn
Jahren schon dafür eine staatliche
Untersuchung zu machen katholische
Kirche evangelische Kirche deutsche
olympischen und dann kann man
systemische Ursachen zum Beispiel
wissenschaftlich seriös feststellen im
Vergleich im Moment gibt es
wissenschaftlich seriös die reden zwar
dauernd von systemischen Ursachen aber
das ist sozusagen das was jeder so als
lieblingsursache hat aber
wissenschaftliche Daten gibt es gar
nicht und die hätte ich gerade mal zu
sagen das ist immer alles sehr
theoretisch Kongress und
wissenschaftlich an der Basis fangen sie
mal die Ermittlungsbehörden wie die
Kirche sich versperrt hat die haben
Priester einfach versetzt haben nicht
Bescheid gesagt haben sie in eine andere
Gemeinde geschickt dort haben sie erneut
Kinder missbraucht und die haben mit den
Ermittlungsbehörden nie kooperiert und
wenn ich dann gehört aber ich kann sagen
ich war Katholik ich bin genau deshalb
ausgetreten von zwei Jahren ich habe
gesagt nein dafür bezahl ich kein Geld
mehr ich spende dieses Geld was ich
jetzt sparen die SOS Kinderdorf und das
ist besser aufgehoben als bei der Kirche
weil ich habe gehört dass ein Kardinal
sich beraten lässt von PR-Agenturen wie
am besten aus diesen Affären rauskommen
und dafür gehen Kirchensteuern drauf und
fragen Sie mal in den Gemeinden da sind
kirchendächer undicht da kommt kein Geld
von Bistum da sind Kindergärten die kein
Geld haben da werden Kindergärten
geschlossen weil das Seniorenheim mehr
Geld bringt ja und dann wunder ich mich
dass kein Nachwuchs mehr also wir sind
in dem gar nicht unterschiedlicher
machen also Sie haben ja vielleicht
gemerkt dass ich die Bischöfe nicht
besonders verteidigt habe aber ich
glaube also ich bin nicht in die Kirche
eingetreten wegen Bischöfen ich trete
doch nicht aus wegen Bischöfen die
völlig überfordert sind mit der
Situation glaube ich auch aber ich
glaube angesichts der Tatsache das ist
eine wertekrise gibt in dieser
Gesellschaft ja und dass man jungen
Menschen nicht einfach sagen können ja
Konsum bis zum Abwinken oder so ich habe
Drogenabhängige behandelt und so die
einfach sagen es ist sinnlos ich habe
einen jungen Menschen auf der
Intensivstation gehabt der der Wacht aus
dem Koma auf der hatte versucht sich mit
Tabletten das Leben zu nehmen und sagt
der Doktor was ist für Sie der Sinn des
Lebens ja und dann habe ich mit ihm über
meinen Glauben gesprochen und nachher
einen Kollegen geschickt damit er auch
noch mal die ärztliche Untersuchung
macht das heißt wir müssten eigentlich
den Fokus auf andere Themen legen ja ich
glaube die innerkirchlichen Themen sind
einfach ausgereizt ja das aber dann
müssen wir auch eines tun und da war
nicht ein wenig vor weil sie sagen es
kann so ein bisschen ja bei den SOS
Kinderdorf und es ist besser angelegt
jetzt liegt es mir fern ich zahle auch
ordentlich Kirchensteuer also meine Frau
auch evangelisch also für beide
so unsere Kinder waren in einer
evangelischen Kindertagesstätte und da
wurden zumindest in den frühesten Zeiten
Gebete andere Dinge mit vermittelt so
ich glaube schon dass man alleine nicht
immer nur sagen kann die wollen das
alles schließen und ähnliches die der
Druck der da entsteht auch bei den
Kosten ist natürlich auch enorm und er
müsste man wenn man die Kirchen stärken
will denen auch aufgeben zu sagen gerade
in diesen Bereichen ja der der Erziehung
der Bildung anderer Dinge da braucht ihr
mehr Standkraft und wenn ihr das lasst
ihn euren Schulen in euren Kitas mit den
ganz normalen wertevermittlungen hätten
wir wesentlich mehr gewonnen was
passiert denn im Moment in den Schulen
da gibt's dann Ethik
evangelischen oder katholischen
Unterricht bekommen
ja aber ich finde was ist denn das
Besondere an der katholischen Kirche ich
bewundere die katholischen Kirche
allerdings nicht wegen ihrem
Missionsauftrag den sie ja davon
formulieren in einer technischen
Gesellschaft und zwar Spitzen sondern
ich bewundere die katholische Kirche
dafür dass sie als Institution
anderthalb 2000 Jahre fast überlebt hat
und warum hat sie als Institution
überlebt ja nicht nur weil sie dann
internes Fundament hatte sondern weil
sie es geschafft hat als Institution der
Weltkirche zu sein ich glaube das ist
auch der eigentliche Hintergrund vom
Zölibat dass meine verhindern will dass
die Kirchen auseinanderfallen in so
einer Familie betrieben wo dann der
Vater auf den Sohn vererbt das gab es ja
alles Geschichte schon mal das war
glaube ich der ursprünglich Hintergrund
und
das ist der jetzt die Frage ob diese
Institution Kirche wenn sie Sinn
entleert selber ist also ihren
Missionsauftrag nicht mehr erfüllt in
einer säkularen Gesellschaft
ob sie dann als Institution eigentlich
ohne zusammenfällt und das ist ja genau
der Punkt also natürlich ist die Kirche
zum Beispiel ist ein gigantischer
Arbeitgeber ein große weite Teile
unseres Wohlfahrtsstaates werden über
Kirchen abgeregelt da gab es immer die
diskussionskirchliche Arbeitsrecht das
hat allerdings mit der katholischen
Nächstenliebe oder sonst irgendetwas wie
relativ wenig zu tun das sind das sind
Institutionen die Einrichtung betreiben
und die Einrichtungen müssen am Ende mit
plus minus 0 abschließen und diese
Trägerschaften z.B von Kindergärten das
ist ja nur formal er will eigentlich
auch wollen viele katholische Gemeinden
das gar nicht mehr machen
und ja gut aber findet halt kein anderer
Frage weitere 2000 Jahre schafft das die
Kirche und dass sie so lange noch geben
aber das hat er eben sehr gut gesagt es
ist tatsächlich die einzige Institution
die 2000 Jahre bestanden hat und das hat
sie geschafft auch in ganz schlimmen
Kris natürlich geschafft in dem sich
immer auch wieder verändert hat und
wirklich die neue Zeit sich angegurt und
ich fand so wie Papst franziskus
angetreten ist der wird natürlich auch
jetzt kritisiert ist ja auch okay ja
aber ich glaube vieles von dem was er
gemacht hat auch die kurienreform die
ich eben genannt habe die Art und Weise
wie er Flüchtlinge in den Mittelpunkt
gestellt hat wir nach Lampedusa gefahren
ist wir auch ökologisch bei der
Klimakatastrophe sich sich engagiert das
finde ich wichtig dass wir eben nicht
nur globale Konzerne haben die
ökonomisch erfolgreich sind Google
Amazon und so sondern das ist eine
einzige Institution gibt es gibt der der
Islam ist auch eine Weltregion aber das
ist nicht eine Institution ist ja schon
in Deutschland schwierig
aber das ist eine Institution gibt die
das zusammenhält das finde ich wichtig
und da finde ich manchmal müssen wir
Deutschen auch eine etwas weniger sag
ich mal nur auf Deutschland
konzentrierte Sichtweise haben wir haben
jetzt diskutiert beim synonalen Weg zum
Beispiel über die Frage der Segnung von
homosexuellen Partnerschaften das kann
man diskutieren
bekommen beim Sinne okay bekommen beim
soldatenweg aber es kann dazu führen das
war aber gar nicht im Blick das habe ich
ein komischerweise auch nicht gefragt
dass einige afrikanische Priester jetzt
nicht mehr mit deutschen katholische
Priester nicht mehr mit deutschem
Priestern zusammen Messe feiern werden
weil in afrikanischen Ländern ist es zum
Teil gibt es die Todesstrafe der Papst
hat sich jetzt gegen die Todesstrafe für
Homosexuelle eingesetzt in Afrika und
hat Gegenwind bei den Katholiken auch
bekommen also nicht sehr aber immerhin
das heißt wenn wir mal so global denken
ist die Frage warum Sexualität finde ich
wo konservative Katholiken in
Deutschland und progressive Katholiken
sich einnehmen können die Frage der
Todesstrafe für Homosexuelle dass man
sich dagegen mal einsetzt und bei der
Frage die Römer ich kenn das ja so ein
bisschen wie die Römer dann über die
deutschen reden die sagen auch Segnung
von homosexuellen Partnerschaften da
macht es doch ja müsst ihr immer eine
Erlaubnis von uns hören man haben müsste
es immer schriftlich aber wir wollen es
immer dann schriftlich haben und dann
auch selber loben dass auch so
durchsetzen und das kann auch zu
tatsächlich zu Verwerfungen in der
globalen Kirche führen und da finde ich
den Wert dass es diese Kirche universal
gibt schon sehr hoch ja das wird auch
nicht in Deutschland glaube ich so ich
nehme das ja nur am Rande so mit ich
habe andere Themen aber ist glaube ich
auch nur eine diese deutsche spezifische
bornheit das kann man ja wirklich sagen
dass sie eigentlich nicht mehr über den
eigenen Tellerrand hinausschauen weil
weil z.B nur ein Beispiel dass sie mal
irgendwann mal gelesen habe für die
katholische Kirche in Brasilien ist ja
eigentlich nur katholisches Land und da
haben es dann wirklich amerikanische
radikale geschafft weite Teile mit ihrem
Missionsauftrag der Bevölkerung zu
sicher rüber zu ziehen mit ganz ganz
roten Thesen ja aber das zeigt natürlich
oder so wie ähm welche Kraft sondern
missionarische Arbeit immer noch haben
kann in einem Volk was oder bei Menschen
die spirituelles und da werden sie ganz
katholisch an dieser Stelle
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie